it really does feel like it's on purpose
but i think the reality is the democrats
are just
looting the vault you vote for them and
they run in and they grab as much as
they can and they run out
they sign bills that guarantee their
future they're extracting the system and
it's getting worse
so my friends i bring you to the ever
ever
uh uh the neverending story how about
that of san francisco
i remember the first time i heard about
san francisco's poop patrol
do you know about san francisco's poop
patrol yeah so they like you know some
cities have a fire department
everybody's got a fire department maybe
you've got a volunteer fire department
you're living up on a mountain or
something
maybe you got to you got a local police
department or sheriff's department san
francisco has a poop department
it is a publicly funded poop unit that
goes around
with specialized tools for cleaning up
human waste because
their streets are littered with it the
new york times reports
san francisco's shoplifting surge the
mundane crime of shoplifting has spun
out of control in san francisco
forcing some chain stores to close i
believe it was what 17
walgreens stores because the police said
they're no longer going to arrest people
for these petty crimes
you see a video of these women in
walgreens and they're just shoveling
makeup products cosmetics into bags
because the cops won't come
they're not going to bother with it
anymore the democrats said the police
system is oppressive
let's not have it
and so you don't well so in new york
apparently
there was a a series of shoplifting
things that were happening
so more of like the cbs cvs and
walgreens were starting to put more
stuff behind lock and key
and cynthia nixon being the great
limousine liberal that she is
tweeted out about how she went to her
corner cvs and she saw stuff
behind lock and key and she was so
offended at this time that people were
struggling
to make ends meet that they thought that
this was the best way to handle it i
mean
that's that that's why like when people
say liberalism is disorder i'm like
that's so not nice to say and then i'm
like
actually but it may be a disorder but we
can't let them take the word
liberalism because that's certainly not
what it is i know but like
the the the idea that you see you see
things behind lock and key in a cvs
and and and instead of thinking about
isn't this terrible that we are we have
this scourge
of shoplifting to the point that shop
owners are required to put stuff behind
lock and key
instead you think isn't it awful at this
time when people are struggling to eat
that people feel like they have to hide
things for
uh this is this is the cycle of
democrats here's what happens
someone shoplifts and get arrested and
gets arrested
and then people outside are filming and
the person screaming my hands you're
hurting me i can't breathe and they're
like this is bad he was only shoplifting
like this is crazy
like what are these cops doing so then
they all protest they smash a bunch of
windows and they burn
places down and the city says people
people we've heard your cries
we will no longer arrest shoplifters
then all of a sudden
and this is actually what happens
walgreens sees a wave of shoplifting
and so then walgreens puts things behind
locked cages
and then people start filming it going
walgreens is racist
they are racist because the only things
that they're covering up are the
products used by minority communities
it's like but there's no cops to stop
the shoplifting so they have to lock the
products up now
now you're complaining about what you
advocated for
that's the system they say we must
abolish the police because the police
are oppressive
then crime skyrockets see the police
weren't doing anything anyway they
weren't keeping our community safe
no no you got rid of the cops you
defunded them you abolished them what
are you complaining about now
the left is completely predicated on
building coalitions of victims
so all their policies have to be geared
towards creating
new victims no one can ever graduate
from
victimhood it's why like look gay people
for years and years and years said we
get the right to marry the right to open
you know openly serve the military like
our work here is gonna be done
when they said actually now it's lgbt
[Music]
a plus right two because you can't no
one's ever
allowed to leave you're never allowed to
graduate out a victim the fact is is the
gay people in this country
have more freedom than anybody any any
other country in the entire planet
they've been the most successful civil
rights movement
of all time in record time people should
be high-fiving
instead you've got the left trying to
convince them
that actually you're still oppressed
my favorite uh article i think was from
the root it said
black men are the white people of black
people yeah
like something like that and it was like
wait what they needed
to find some kind of power dynamic the
the woke left
so it's not it's not all of them but
they do align behind this
they only believe that there is no truth
but power
so that that was a that was a a
fascistic ideology
that the only thing that mattered was
power because truth is irrelevant if you
could
remove anyone who believed the truth the
left doesn't believe in objective
reality
then i mean the like overall there are
obvious obviously some leftists who are
like
andy woke communists but doesn't matter
because they still vote for biden who
then puts in well policy
they they don't believe in objective
reality they do believe in power
dynamics
they literally follow tenets of fascism
now i know they're not ultra-right
nationalists
so spare me left us when you're like the
true you're doomed
they are authoritarian race-based
identitarian
generalized identitarian and they have
fascistic tendencies
call it whatever you want i don't care
they're psychopaths
well it's like the the the left is also
years ago
the left decided to adopt this politics
of intersectionality
where you had to be for everybody else's
agenda
the right has always been this coalition
of kind of diverse like
i'm the gun people and the abortion
people and they can agree on this and
disagree on that
and it's it's always been you know this
kind of raucous
coalition of folks the left decided a
long time ago that they had to stamp out
any opposition to each other everyone
you you couldn't just be
like i'm the pro-choice democrat you
also had to be i'm the pro
everything else and you had to be at 100
and that's why they've been so effective
is because they've made
like what what does you know the human
rights campaigns the largest lgbt
organization
in the country takes all kinds of
positions on crap that have absolutely
nothing to do with gay people whatsoever
because the left has been so effective
at intersectional politics you have to
buy in on everything well this is the
example i love to give is an
organization called free press
freepress.net
what do you think an organization called
freepress.net advocates for as a
nonprofit
sounds like freedom of the press so
would you be surprised at all to learn
that they advocated for the censorship
of alex jones
wow i remember when i saw that i know
people there and i hit him up i'm like
why are you guys advocating for
censorship like hate speech is bad i'm
like
isn't that just press like i don't get
it what's the difference between your
opinion and their opinion well they're
hate speech i'm like
free press it doesn't say free press for
some
i guess that's what that's it changed
they changed intersectionality
all of a sudden you had to support all
of the causes yep even if it defied your
own principles principles were gone
and then i love it i love it i had a
meeting with some people from vice
and they're like you're like i don't
know man like people change you know
it's like they that stuff doesn't fly
and i was like bro
do you think maybe you changed and then
these these two people were like
yeah yeah there was an article in vice
about uh an
app that you take a picture of a woman
and then it uses
ai to show her topless and they called
it like this horrible app
shows a women woman topless and then i
was like you see that article
i was like do you know what vice would
have titled that article in 2012
this amazing yeah it shows you women's
because it was meant to be in your face
edgy angry
something happened to vice where they
became feminists
and that's when they were like yeah
you're right
but we can't do that anymore it's like
of course you can you just you just
you're scared like why can't you do it
your ratings are in the gutter your
views are in the gutter
clearly people liked the punk rock fu
attitude
and what did you give them instead
demure scared
feminism yeah that's exactly what's
gonna save your company
now they're in the gutter that the
disney wrote off their 500 million
dollar whatever investment advice to
zero
congratulations getting woke was it
worth it well because it won't go bro
they've everything it's same thing's
happened in comedy
you know i mean comedy has been
absolutely ruined by
the woke left you know and it's why the
handful of people who
your push back against wilker actually
like some of the most
powerful activists in this country which
is so
crazy i mean at its base like comedy was
supposed to be funny it was supposed to
be equal opportunity offenders pick on
everybody
like slaughter all the sacred cows yeah
instead
you watch like late night you know tv
over the last four or five years
they're telling the same joke on every
channel every night
snl is unwatchable from start to finish
and it has been
because the number one point of comedy
was to make people laugh and instead
they decided the number one point had to
be to toe
clapter it's called clapter it's where
people aren't laughing at the jokes
they're clapping because they agree with
the political message right so these
comedy shows during the trump era like
snl
they would get alec baldwin to do this
impression that in
no way resembled trump it was the
weirdest thing like trump wouldn't ever
just freeze and then hold his mouth open
in a weird way that didn't happen
so alex like alec baldwin was just
making fun of the guy
like he wasn't doing an impression it
was just people laughing say hated trump
there was no substance there was no
humor well i shouldn't say there's no
humor
if you find it funny fine but it was
clapter they would get a guy on stage
it'd be like trump is so dumb and then
everyone go and they all laugh and clap
at each other it's like
okay well you look at all the other late
night hosts and it's all the exact same
thing and john oliver is like the worst
that guy just like lies all the time
it's it's hilarious how awful the show
is
it's formulaic little timothy over here
says trump is bad and everyone laughs
and i'm like what's funny about that
well i mean that's the thing though is
that like i mean
i would love if by the way if alec
baldwin had actually done
a good trump impression i would have
laughed yeah the
impression he did actually got worse as
it went along he wasn't
doing an impression no it was like the
same thing and again like
i laughed all the time i enjoy comedy
that makes fun of everybody
there's plenty of things to make fun of
trump about that could have been
funny but it never was because it was it
was all about the political it was all
about trying to get the
the clap the applause line it's like
after the hillary clinton
loss you know when the the snl did the
skit with
you know the woman coming out and you
know hillary and like singing the song
and it was like what am i watching
we got this art on the wall you can't
you can't you guys can't see it in the
cameras but it's from george alex opolis
and it's uh one part of a comic about
trump it's trump
struggling to eat what appears to be
like broccoli and he can't
he's wearing a bib that says bib boy in
the original comic he says like my hands
are too small and he's struggling to eat
it
what's funny about this is it's not
really making fun of trump
it's making fun of the left as they
would make fun of trump
so when when i look at it i laugh but
i'm not laughing because trump has a
little hands and wears a bib
i'm laughing because that's the the
garbage joke the left hand is the only
thing they had
you turn on family guy trump was orange
literally
massively fat with tiny little hands and
i'm like
who are you talking to right trump
doesn't have little hands i get the joke
the first time but is that it
that was it that was it they were just
there it is it is like
a bunch of drones all being with the
applause sign flashing that's what tiny
hands was
they'd go hey hey ian tiny hands
it's like okay that's not i get it
whatever
apparently comedy's crushing it in texas
right now the
the creek in the cave are you familiar
with that is that rogans
well no it was uh independent thing run
by rebecca out in new york and they shut
down because of covid
and reopened in austin and now they're
nice i keep here it's apparently one of
the hottest spots in austin right now
awesome yeah but you you do have some
people who are willing to say f you and
kind of push the ball because ryan long
obviously we've had on the show several
times
it's just good luck getting it on
network tv that's that's the problem
no no i don't i don't i don't think
these people want that anymore
i think the comedians are like why you
can't make jokes i mean
what's his name uh got arrested for talk
for george carlin yeah carlin got
arrested for talk saying that's awesome
eight words you can't say seven words
you can't say and you set them anyway
and then
so like that's the does not jive with
late night tv it's it's always kind of
cool
to to land like a tonight show spot as a
comedian
but i think like you said about the
republicans seeking like the new uh
a good word in the new york times like
getting an award or getting that one
moment in the spotlight is not really
it's not really that like the
counterculture has become the
establishment
like i'm literally sitting there
listening to siriusxm
and the rage against the machine tom
morello came on talking about his like
channel and blah blah blah and i was
like
like rage against the machine is now
rage for the machine rage on behalf of
the machine yeah like i'm like this
it's the least like right now like all
of these people have completely sold out
everything that they were supposedly
there's all the counter culture and punk
rock and all that it's all dead
they killed it all it's all just milk
toast boring crap
now you know it's like tom morello was
like what's up everybody this is tom
morello from rage against the machine
check out my album you can order it on
amazon or find it at walmart
it's produced by shenzhen slave labor
youth throughout the big problem with
the record in music industry is like uh
auto tune
and computers like how you can you can
record your
one tr one like uh segment of like uh
one what do they call it a beat or like
uh yeah
you know you can like 16 bars you can
record it and then stop
and then record the next 16 bars and
then cut them together in the computer
which is totally disjointed what are you
talking about if you want to like sing a
song normally back in the day
what does that have to do with what we
were talking about it's cheap into the
art you know back in the day go in and
you have to
kick it in one track and it has to be
good because that's the way it has
little to do
with the rage rage on behalf of the
machine 14 year olds don't
realize the passion that is involved
with art because they don't have to
you're totally doing it for them i'm not
even talking about the same thing if
you know when when hip-hop came out
people called them demo tapes they said
it was not real music
i'm not gonna have an argument out what
is or isn't enjoyable music i'm having
an argument about punk rock bands that
are supporting walmart and amazon yeah
well you can't be punk if you're gonna
rely on a computer to do yes you can
do punk rock's great old mannion get
with the program
i'm not even going to use rock punk rock
is hard
core it's not you don't rely on a
machine to fix it for you you're making
excuses for your bad music i'm pointing
out why
you know it's amazing to digress but on
the music thing here
sean ono lennon is like one of the best
follows on
he is and like i'm like then the guy is
not even saying anything that's that far
out there he's just asking questions
sometimes and i'm realizing
that's revolutionary right now on the
left somebody
who's john lennon john lennon's son with
yoko ono
like so he's got these kind of like the
background that's bulletproof you can't
accuse shawn ono lennon
of being like a white nationalist so
he's the guy who can say like hey by the
way
have are things going too far and start
asking the question and i'm like
that's so crazy that we've gotten to a
point where that's revolutionary you
know that
that's actually revolutionary is now
doing something so
yeah baby step of just saying hey is
this going too far
i should i should just write parody punk
music that's just like
super in favor of the establishment and
like massive multinational corporations
just write a punk rock song like joe
biden rocks i can't even go back i can't
so i used to like rage as a machine but
i can't even listen to their music
anymore
because all of it feels so fraudulent at
this point
to be fair like killing in the name like
have there was a video i saw was funny
was conservatives dancing to
killing in the name and i'm like you
guys know that songs about like
white supremacist cops who are murdering
black people like that's black lives
matter
i guess the interesting thing is the
response i saw from this i tweeted about
it were people like dude they know what
the song's about
like they legit don't like cops who are
racists killing black people
the left just thinks all conservatives
agree with that and i'm like wow that's
actually kind of a crazy point
like you could have liked rage against
the machine and then
and then i i had this funny moment where
i was talking to zantifa guy
this was in berkeley and he had a knife
and he was like all those people are
fascists and i was like all
those people in in in the park right
over there like yeah they're all
fascists man
and i was like do you think those people
are pro-gun and he's like yeah
and i was like do you know why they're
pro-gun he's like
i don't know i was like isn't it because
they're scared of a tyrannical
government taking over so they want guns
to protect themselves from
fascism and he was like oh
yeah i guess and i'm like so it kind of
sounds like they're the ones who don't
like fascism and they like
want guns to protect themselves see like
the left has this assumption that
the right loves the government and i'm
like yeah maybe some elements are like
supportive of the government
but like the gadsden flag and like all
that stuff about like small government
i'm not surprised they're dancing to
rage against the machine
where they're preaching about racist
cops like being bad
because conservatives are also skeptical
of government but they do support cops
that's why it was kind of paradoxical
but so in a way i feel like kind of the
bases have kind of flipped over the last
20 years with the the the base of the
the
right-wing base getting more and more
like skeptical
of authority skeptical of the government
more like self-reliant
you you're less interested in foreign
adventurism
you're less you know you're more
skeptical of wall street and big
business and the the left has completely
and totally sold out to all of that
again yeah gets your point about rage
against machines selling their you know
their seats i don't know walmart
actually but they probably are i'm sure
they are but
like they've sold all of that out the
the
occupy wall street people are now the
party of
wall street well the occupy wall should
split up so
a decent amount of those people became
trump supporters i remember i went to
the deplorable
in dc and i was just like i'm like i
didn't think anybody there would know
who i was and i saw two people and they
were like tim huge fans
like so cool to see you here nice to
meet you and i was like oh i didn't
realize i'd have fans who were like
trump supporters and they were like oh
no we were down at occupy wall street
the whole time
i was like you're wearing maga hats like
yeah yeah trump's the guy man and i was
like wow
but like when you think about it these
are people who are angry at the banking
establishment angry at the political
establishment
and donald trump came in and said bring
the jobs back secure the borders
that sounds about right but also they
were voting against hillary we got to be
honest
hillary usurped that from bernie and uh
people voted against hillary just like
they voted against trump this time they
voted against hillary clinton that
nasty woman if she had she was just so
hateable
if she just she was yeah
you know in a way that like biden is
really not that hateful
yeah he's just kind of you know and you
almost feel bad for him you feel like
god i wish
i wish he wasn't without this over with
yeah like you know yeah
you know how the story ends hurry up and
get to the end of the story like where's
like hillary every time she said
something
it came across as so smarmy and so
elitist and you're just like
oh god i want you to lose so bad
please lose her email scandal was insane
like that what she burned like 10 000 30
30 000 emails that she just destroyed
and disrupted with like talks with
sidney blumenthal about going into libya
as when she was secretary of state she's
got
after she was she she was she's so
entitled uh ian ian
she said she said it was yoga it was
emails about yoga yeah her daughter's
wedding oh no doubt yeah her daughter's
wedding
yeah it's like i just again she was the
perfect opponent for
trump yeah because it was the
establishment
versus you know i'm not the first person
to say this but it was
you know it was bushwood yeah it was
rodney dangerfield
it was the you know it was the
caddyshack you know
have you ever seen dogma no you don't
see the movie dogma have you seen dogma
you guys haven't seen the movie dog
what's the kevin smith first kevin smith
movie i missed with jane simon bob and
like basically the story is
loki and uh what was the other the other
angel
bartleby two angels fell from heaven
they want to go back
man i can't believe you guys haven't
seen the movie anyway there's a point in
the movie
where this demon his name is azrael he
wants to end all existence because he
hates being in hell
and so there's one scene where he
summons or like
yeah something called the golgothan it's
a demon made of human excrement
so golgotha i guess i'm i don't know
this is where they uh crucified people
right right and so when people get
crucified all their wastes
you know like drops out and so the idea
was that all that waste from
all these evil people formed a demon
called the golgothan
hillary clinton is that but for the
political elites so like
after a a huge really long congressional
session
and all of the members of congress and
senate run to the bathrooms and then
flush at the same time
hillary emerges from that from that muck
and
climbs out yeah and then she goes up on
stage vote for me
you're like i'll take the orange guy
right ladies
you know outside of the silliness she
represented all of the filth
of the political establishment more so
than anyone we'd seen in a really long
time and she never even tried to shine
it up
that was the thing that was so amazing
about hillary it was like i mean look
bill was garbage i mean he was total
trash but bill tried to come across
as i feel you're paying you know he
tried to be likable
like well hillary figured out a long
time ago like i'm completely unlikable
so i'm just going to go with it
you know who would you rather vote for
mitt romney or hillary clinton
i mean i guess hillary clinton really
yeah you want to know why
because i think maybe she would like at
least keep us safe internationally
you know like she's going to start with
war with russia i know
look that's i don't know i feel like the
worst thing that romney would do was
just extract value from the system and
watch it fall apart
hillary would actively get us involved
in conflicts but it probably would too
i guess i guess the question is would
you vote for the same person that's
probably not a good analogy
they're both just so awful yeah they're
both terrible yeah and by the way
it's another thing we talk about things
that trump has exposed trump exposed
people like mitt romney
you know like and it's it's so it's so
beautiful the guy who was the 2012
nominee of the republican party
is getting booed in his home state by
republican delegates
because they hate the guy and you know
what the truth is is that mitt romney
has always hated his own voters
he has always hated the dirty unwashed
masses that he had to rely on
and like it's it's so gorgeous to
finally see people waking up to the fact
that you want to know what
he never liked you yeah he's hated your
guts paul ryan did too none of these
people liked you
you know it's you know it's really funny
like hillary clinton definitely doesn't
like you
and they say i see these memes on the
left where like trump doesn't like you
he's using you and i'm like have you
ever seen trump
interact with people i've been at trump
rallies you know what the man does he
hugs and like shakes hands and he like
smiles and he's a germaphobe
it's like the craziest thing when he
walks over he's saying autographs from
people he would do a rally and he would
come down
and he would meet and greet people have
long conversations with them i go to i
went to trump tower
i went to the ice cream shop and i asked
and the steakhouse and asked the
employees like you guys ever see trump
down here and they're like yeah every so
often do you like them they're like he's
great
he like walks over and just hands you
100 bill it's awesome and i'm like wow
they really like the guy
hillary clinton the stories we hear
about her she's on like an air force
jet and she holds her wine glass up goes
and these like air force officers are
like lady i'm not getting your wine for
you and she just
had to pour her wine for her the stories
about hillary are that she's despicable
and evil and nasty and then you look
before donald trump ran for president
everybody loved them
oh god yeah they loved the guy yep
absolutely by the way so 2011
i got trump invited to speak at his
first cpac
and trump comes and he's a total mess
before his
speech he's mad it was late like he
went to the wrong entrance it was kind
of a disaster
goes up there gives a barn burner speech
he gets done we're walking out and they
decide they want to leave through the
service entrance
so we're going out the service entrance
and literally he stopped and shook hands
with and took his picture
with every single bus boy
waiter house keeper like every i
was it was the first time like i watched
him give a speech and it was like
it was trump being trump you know and i
was like i never didn't think it was
like trump
had some political future and then i
watched him interact with all of those
working-class people
on the way out and i was like wait a
second like
there actually may be something here
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you